yeah you got me crime I'm late today
what's up guys happy Monday
yeah pretty cool day today we're gonna
check out Hades early access game play
was announced during VGA as I believe
last week the next game from supergiant
games you can get it on the epic store
right now $19.99 if you want to try
playing it even though in the
description technically I said first
time I played for like 5 minutes just
now just to kind of like make sure I
knew some of the buttons and it actually
um there's you will see well start and
you will start a new game but uh there
are some cool parallels here some other
game total of Hades reminding us of the
inevitable fate which we all share I
however mean to tell you such a tale
listen carefully yeah it's supergiant
games makers a fashion that transistor
hire I didn't actually play pyre I heard
good things about it so as to help with
this place also have yes just so aware
today I also have a like one ranged
attack so I have that
- damages - from the acutight yeah it's
you level up as well as will do in a
second there's also like interesting
things that you can do all that you can
do to like cane them into the wall for
more like a little bit like it's like a
roguelike as well so you know you're
gonna go through these dungeons multiple
times you're gonna get different level
up and level up and then also you'll
take back like your headquarters and
after the fact
till then let you
like the Dodge well maybe maybe you can
upgrade it to more like the Dodge like
it kind of like he'll slow off of the
end of it I guess it's got to be
thankful low is next week
let's get you up on Olympus two apart
beginning here with me he's really she
has to be oh so now we get to upgrade
something because we talked to our buddy
our friend Athena so divine strike which
is interesting because you can deflect
the tax so we might take that - slightly
slower I don't want that and when I take
the attack damage you gotta see here
your power fused with mine I mean that
the it gives me that deflect and then I
think there's also an ability I switch
this might be grinding the later from
what I've seen so far
the comment feels satisfying though the
only thing is I kind of wish that -
[Music]
a little bit more like but you know it's
early access so we just got 10 of those
currencies and human use later I can
find as I said I can't kill myself
which is Oh way I could deflect that so
now that I have that ability I'm not
even that like well I shouldn't say that
because I don't know that for a fact but
I know that like time to go through it
again at least the second time I did
earlier dead I saw shiny like a
different I didn't go through the same
level each exit is its own reward
there's a key for that and then there's
like more gems the key I think also
unlocks more stuff Luke to nuts says
this week actually
you got a play it to be honest it feels
good I actually liked the character
stuff or the art direction in the wall
first
obviously
there's two fears if there will
eventually be like right I know I think
you can get items as you progress
increase your max health what did I tell
you excuse me as well as um wonder where
I can use this as well as heal you a bit
turn up your mic okay all right oh whoa
wow that's a little bit loud for myself
all right
yeah I only gained the ability to
deflect projectiles there after I got
that skill so here's to see if that
translates over to like
oh yeah the this the weightiness of the
attacks and all that feel good
[Music]
oh gosh
[Music]
are they God sent our heart so we gained
25 overall health and then also gained
HP alright going to the next area
I believe there's like other weapons
other weapons as well so try have to
unlock that stuff and more ability
[Music]
okay
oh it got you to lay though
so you just basically go to different
rooms won't you now we have two keys
which is good so there's I don't know
what that is it's got a skull in there
and that's like a potion thing sixteen
health though huh looking good
get that gold hit those pots for the
gold early levels are easy
yeah I'm sure it'll get harder we'll go
this way because I don't know if I can
deal with the day with the skull right
now I hear that it's a roguelike kind of
you'll see cuz like when you die you
pretty much like start over but you also
gain stuff so yeah we don't have enough
to buy so I could upgrade char on
well I get to see you Carol mate Carol
just minding my own business taking in
the sights and I think what's that you
got some soft way as to sale Wolf's
agent to get early access it's 1999 it's
on the epics store this is developed by
supergiant games who made Bastion
transistor as well as higher ways of the
Stygian boatman Carol I sprawled about
that'll be me
[Music]
do we just save maybe you Souls you take
the boat or take
I don't know I'm worried to spend
anything right now just because I feel
like I'm gonna die soon
oh define I just seal it up converse
this is Hades
I promise Odom
alright eight health no problem good
whoa dog that barely always the boss
alright well I got that last swing the
last swing kind of pushes it back
really real sketch Batum oh no problem
who's ready for the ripped number one
here riperino yeah all right so here we
go here's first death here which will
trigger us into like another area and
stuff like that which will give you a
little bit more back on here damn it
failed time to like I'm get back to the
house of Hades welcome to the house of
Hades work wait I know you
guess that means you to hide out there
huh I don't don't be sad though pretty
much everybody die sometime
some of us more than others
how are the inputs are their combos lady
dragon I'm pretty early on in the game
so like it's like oops well I know my
sword but it does like a three swing
kind of combo in itself which ends with
that one ender that pushes forward you
have one projectile again I don't have
that many abilities yet and so I'm not
sure if there's more combo I'm sure
there's gotta be though cuz there's just
so many miss joy there's more abilities
than one so I'm sure you can combo into
certain things you watch over things
phone me won't you boy there's stupid
boy Hades I told you nobody gets out of
here whether alive will did Mallory so
unfortunately I can't read your text so
I have a translation there for that so
I'll just be on my way again I'm a soul
killer yeah sorry epic be on your way
indeed what do I care I'm trying to
reach the surface
you have come home what was it now 100 K
do not despair and hold your resolve
child tell me something as the goddess
Athena thus been true to her words and
her willingness to support she has Nix
I'm grateful that you put us into
contact to ever explained it is did you
get a dog I'm in it gladdens me to hear
it seldom Julian's consort with those
boys they're like and say Diablos being
so Justin's cause for an exception well
see here in a second once I get to this
other room I think there's stuff we can
potentially get with my back room did
you miss me so here's another thing you
can do you can use the mirror
I got these gems while playing so we can
so far we have four things available to
us we can either increase our shadow
presence by one which is gives 10%
damage when you strike foes from behind
or cathodic vitality trink makes you
heal by one when you enter each chamber
that seems ok maybe it's better when you
level it higher Oh actually I can't
level these two infernal soul each rank
gives you another ok so two projectiles
instead of 1 and greater reflex
each rank lets you chain one more - in a
row ok that seems pretty cool I guess
we'll take the the heal and see how that
goes
I can't can't afford anymore so good to
go see how that affects things going on
the beds of print Zagreus lie in a
perpetual state of utter disarray
despite his Lord and Master of the house
that is it I am on PC this is on PCP so
this is what I meant by those keys that
we had unfortunately we can only afford
maybe this bone arrow we could try that
that looks like a shield and that looks
like a spear so and then there's also
this I'll have to come actually - I
don't know give someone something to
earn the keepsake that goes here yeah I
don't know how that works yet here will
unlock the bone arrow there we go
so looks like knocked there's a hot
secret there's another wide of hold Expo
flashing okay it's got some character to
them I like it like the eyeballs I
reminds me of like the the bow in our
like monster holding X to release X
while flashing
I just have to kill nice place you got
here boyo
oh the small talk already I'm here to do
a job so let me have it
give me everything you got okay I don't
remember having you on payroll mate
who's your supervisor well I'm not about
to rap my sources pal just try and beat
it out of me
yeah like a guy's like a coin in his
mouth too if she insists yeah keep going
oh when it's flashing okay it's like
okay it's it's like a skill-shot thing
where like if you release at the right
time it does more there you go that's
gonna be pretty tough the ties
first get past the wretched shades of
Tartarus this isn't done and loving the
art you know for sure so the farthest
chamber I reached so far as panel 27 at
least in this build of the game find a
way up top from there and after that all
right let's give it another shot one
yeah I mean I'm digging it
we'll see if well if we're stuck with
the bow now or not but monster hunter
poet yeah
what's this is this really him
okay in the name of Hades I accept this
message okay so we get Zeus is blood so
now we get another ability so lightning
strike your attacks and made a chain
lightning bolt when you damage a foe it
seems pretty good your special image to
chain lightning bolt when you damage a
foe or your - it makes a lightning bolt
strike let's do the chain the old uncle
Zeus lending in symbology today Oh but
okay this bow is kind of hard to use yes
sniped composed of such innumerable
ever-shifting interlocking chambers the
underworld of Lord Hades all but one
good thing I'm not dead yeah I got the
Molly - okay so it seems like maybe you
get like you start our view run with the
new weapon and you just use that weapon
for that run let go
just go shot deals good one here we are
Legolas yeah sniper Reno's do we get
that plus one health yeah okay so each
room plus one helps I kind of Miss okay
that volley does really crappy damage
[Music]
[Music]
we kind of have to hold the bones are we
doing kind of better I guess in the
sense that like we're gaining more the
beginning here I hope see these comes to
switch yeah I hope so too but they've
they've definitely some games on switch
or a ring they put the only problem with
the bow oh gosh
the only thing I was going to save is
that it might be a little bit more
boring for you to watch it up is because
I haven't cut a lot to keep going on
[Music]
okay so I get better at that I don't
know what this does this one was bound
to show up I guess in the name of Hades
I accept this message okay oh maybe this
is from Harry's okay I have to say most
intrusive roguelike game I believe
selves yeah because each time you die
you start over and then like that until
we have like a different runs of death
you see I feel like the bows pretty good
but I'm definitely probably not using it
to the best of my ability ooh this is
rare okay so there's differing skill
like determinations I guess you cast
your cast sends a blade rift hurling
forward your special cut not specially
increase your debt instead of your dash
you become a blade rift jeez for a short
time I don't even know what that means
that sounds pretty cool though I think
I'm gonna take the rare with your power
little berries I can buy
who do we spend the coins
the blood gaze guaranteed to spawn a
head so I mean like you get health back
in winter what chamber of riches
requiring the sacrifice of our heart to
access do just by this coin goes in that
comes out they gave us some health back
not very much also have two skills
hey that's our that's our projectile now
you know there's no way we just get that
free right okay we'll take it oh wow
give me that he'll go yeah yeah I like
it
alright that's a door that's a door for
more coins you go from one point or do
we go for the lace of calm and respite
while straps unimaginable in the
underworld occasionally is to be found
in fact so it does seem like there are
some moves where you'll get HP back
which is good because these runs get
difficult obviously so I can either go
for more coins which we use to buy HP or
we can go for this well right go for the
bag with the skull on it because
let's see what's up for sale oh we're at
the boatman again I think and we can
afford nothing big nothing nice at least
buy these so that you could keep on for
the next run or something army level up
your character I'm liking it though just
like in the game for sure definitely got
a get better at it via B move that I
gave
[Music]
volley good more
all the guys are moving nothing yeah
[Music]
imagine throwing two of these holes
I'd be dirty palm of power the power of
the coats okay so now we can level up
our abilities dude I'm taking that and
we're taking that slicing shot it must
have a base up on Olympus hold LT okay
so this tells you your moves all right
cool all right that's got a skull on it
I think we have no choice but to go that
way right all right go get more gold oh
my god I don't know what he's got you
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how are you
Oh
[Music]
Oh Lord they got a second wife
Oh No okay I play perfect how can we
kill one of them though
[Music]
he's got the Duke
Oh
alright it turns out he's junk rat the
fact those bosses are junk rat and job
suicide bombs when you kill them guide
you child you have I won't forget you
next ok so now she's telling me I've
outgrown the house I was ready to like
look at chat celebrate with you tell you
we're probably gonna die in the next
room because we only have 10 health two
casts that was cheap yeah I mean as far
as the fun of like these games is okay
so I can keep the bow or I could switch
back equipment once you unlock it which
is pretty cool I like that I think we're
gonna go with the bow again don't
suppose I can talk you not a chance boyo
I'm paid to take it not to dish it out
now give it to me
skeleton likes getting hit alright go
again
thanks for skipping the dialogue sorry
from sanity I'll stick with it next time
it's just that we listen to Hades
earlier this hammer
so I guess giving you an upgrade back
into tip-top shape point-blank shot your
attacks deal up to 350 percent damage to
nearby exposed yeah okay that's so
that's basically like a shotgunning
attack your attack deals up to 300% but
charges more slowly at the right power
shot deals 250% damage I think perfect
shot might be the way to go just because
I don't think I'm good enough to use
point-blank shot efficiently you know
I'm gonna go with just thinking
our attacks more strong if I climb it
right it looks like it does 75 if I nail
it I'll try to be better about the chats
are y'all it is a big pretty big part of
the time the print steps back into the
underworld its ever-shifting chambers
realigned to frustrate his attempts to
maybe even map it out a fox
no early access games don't count has to
have come out in that year so the
unfortunate thing is we lost that one
ability where we got to throw that
spinny disc which is like a really
really cool ability we're back through
this having nothing we don't even have
Zeus's thing anymore
this fellow seemed like pretty bad
without this instability and without
stupid fools
coins or this on PlayStation yet that I
know
[Music]
don't trust me again I think this is
there's only one heavenly not sure I
know of
oh well several really anyway in the
name of Hades these skills message
eventually from the power of the hunt
helps keep me company so maybe it'll
help you to deadly flourish your special
has a chance to deal critical damage
your cast true shot Oh epic this is epic
your cast deals more damage and seeks
nearest Wow 42 162 I think we have to
take that right after your - after you -
your attack deals critical damage that's
pretty good - I think we got to take the
rare though make that damage the power
of the hunt sounds handy - okay so
potion thingy or more purple Orbeez
oh my god I don't even know what that
does but all I know is our caste thing
is insane how do you do there's traps in
this game y'all and I don't like it
all they drop minds to what it
oh hi Dave this is our very Opie skill
Wow
that can't wait to get that strong with
skills early on and it cracks sure not
gonna complain we just got to enjoy it
so much so that I have to shadow play
we just have to shadow play this this
skill true shot 162 damage with homing
and I can throw 2 of them I think you
before you leave a room you should try
and break everything in the room to get
points to use later okay is that for
like gold pride for gold or anything
that's probably a good point that's a
good shout thank you Goldy wire I
appreciate that or is this just for
environmental day it's that kind of
environmental damage numbskulls
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is supremely poorly he was a recovery on
that moon it's very bad
[Music]
all right well at least we got a key I
guess it's kind of lonely back home it's
not good
according to skip you die in the next
room probably I should have took out the
things that were spawning know what
let's see cyclops jerky
three more encounters bring these we can
afford both alright or just buy a boat
cuz this run is looking pretty bad but
now we can throw three of those big
damaging attack so as long as we don't
run into like another big moneyness hey
princess must look like I'm slacking off
really Old Baldy here but I was just
getting back on my feet a few resistors
don't often leave me be where'd they go
anyway what are you doing here
oh you know just out on a little stroll
as all do me a favor though you see the
fury sisters let them know I was headed
down the way I came from will you oh
I'll let them know alright I hear you
loud and clear your highness
I'll just go about my business now and
you take care
offer the choice of benefits
currency or help
I take the health right sure here you go
look at that burger meal gyro fries
delightful
there's so much recovery on that volume
we were getting gold earlier from this
though so we can either go and get it
okay we gotta go this way yes all right
she might give me another ability which
would be pretty cool
[Music]
I see you
[Music]
at this point we're not even you
Lucas
all right so epic deadly strike here
attack has a chance to deal critical
damage critical chance 60% this seems
pretty good special has a chance to deal
critical chance 34 hunters - we could
have got to earlier kisses rare I think
we just shopping
the RPG slash looter and he just says to
always take the best bet so or like the
highest delineation of something
alright so now there's a boss not sure
what else we're gonna get currently
playing on PC because it's only on PC I
believe early access but who knows if
down the road they won't be on more
platforms because it's a super kind
games it's definitely oh it sees jerks
oh these guys are different they don't
would they have more like way more armor
oh my lord all right oh I guess I should
have big news
she is your mother as I understand we
Olympians rarely consult with the
cathodic God's the Knicks herself
reached out to me about your plight and
I was spurred to act all rares special
are stronger and can deflect yeah I
don't think that I don't know if we want
to use the volley just to deflect your -
you're slightly slower but deals
damaging can deflect resist some traps
forty percent I don't want a slower -
and I don't think I'm ever gonna really
volley so I guess we're taking that the
wisdom of Athena so it looks like you
can get a lot of abilities in one run
she's pretty cool I wonder there's got
to be something that lowers the recovery
on that volley I probably just missed it
earlier but
it was like my damaged
seventy-five on normal charts
for now we're just gonna keep casting
this movie Opie probably not gonna see
it again looks like you can use a
fireman to do damage as well
they're 150 great on them I'm actually
like I put a lot of dead cells was one
of my personal top 10 this year and
goodbye for now
it's definitely scratching some of those
itches for sure and I haven't even got
that deep in this game oh gosh three
pipe bosses oh man all right let me see
is this a review in progress no not at
all this is just GameSpot live we're
live every weekday went into Friday at
11 a.m. I don't review games at GameSpot
I just come on to play games hang out
with you guys show you guys new games if
we can get them early for preview or
we'll just play you know games that just
came out or games that are you know
constantly getting updated you know
sometimes we'll play fortnight destiny
I'm sure we're gonna play anthem the
division and a bunch of other games like
that is this single-player only yes I
believe someone who made it this maybe
for now maybe there would be like
leaderboard stuff in the future I don't
know maybe my way there's something I
don't know about yes but
week
oh I lost my plus-one attack Oh it only
lasted for something
oh crap you can't stay okay plus 20 at
least they get more at some point I
would really like to like get a heal or
something yeah I'll bring reviewers on
interesting sometimes as well just out
[Music]
I just put myself in the corner Oh
please be the end No
and it gets really rough I'm curious
like how it get when you get farther I
don't know if you guys have played it
more but just how you can kind of like
maintain or get HP more because that
what an ability doesn't seem nearly as
good as it used to be yes I have a gift
to give to a friend oh never came over
the house of Hades that dark and
lavishly appointed lair of the
underworlds King is hope not just to him
but who is willful progeny you know I
can hear you out men we're good to see
you lad despite the circumstances
remember your training out there the
pain of death there's but another
obstacle and fear is for the weak take
care of chile's those doors are locked
so can't go that way
Oh service is know I'm for Cerberus I
see you've decided to come home change
your mind yet we're looking for more
pain and suffering so here can I create
a playlist with all of the games are
lying inside that's my job for I know
you told me very appreciate the finer
things you keep telling yourself that
boy but mock you my words sooner or
later this life that you have chosen for
yourself I shall teach you I was right I
guess that one who wasn't that insane
talk at the end of the day I mean it was
good for clearing a single target but it
wasn't as good multiple things that
we're dealing with so this would give us
to heal per room not sure how we unlock
these oh wait it's three keys gotcha
okay so quick temper
each rank gives you plus 20% damage when
you - then attack right away death
defiance
each rank makes you heal up to 21 time
instead of taking lethal damage
or we can get a new weapon I think we
can afford one of the the spear we can
try that if you guys want to see that
maybe try the spear out or the I bet the
shield it's really hard to use well you
guys want you want me to do one of those
abilities or try another weapon or just
use the bow again the courtyard of the
house of Hades is kept neat and orderly
in contrasts of the terrifying sprawl
that lies beyond it's not that orderly
really all round thanks for being a fan
well at least a couple people enough
people from you unlock it so try it up
whoa you can throw it
oh yeah my spear back ok you can't hold
this oh wow it's like God award you hit
attack and comes back oh let's go let's
go oh man this an art pokin a rogue like
that has some RPG elements perhaps all
right let's see what ability we get so
this first area when you come back after
you die seems you randomly get ability
something transpired between the two of
them I'm gonna get one so we can either
deflect the cast is bigger and stronger
and can't deflect
so our be attacked stronger or we just
attack with let's just get the beat to
lighting protection
okay the downside did this versus the
sword is it doesn't look like it has any
like pushback move just looks like a lot
of stabby stabby and
like a four-shot come on
eight Ball corner pocket oh no just like
in real life whipping whipping the pole
shot oh oh wait no I was like can we get
a key from that no Louisville that's why
we got that key
oh all right we got an upgrade weapon
upgrade
I'll check that out I know somebody says
through this version alright sorry the
level is entirely randomized it kind of
seems that way a little bit like you get
different enemies different room tile
sets stuff like that yeah need alright
we are Aquaman so what we'd like to do
your attacks hit farther for up to 130
percent to distant foes your special
which is my javelin throw deals up to
200 percent more damage your special
deals 500 percent damage to armor hmm
want the throw or just the attacks hit
farther this seems like the easiest one
since we're not getting any like special
rare or epic version of an ability
unfortunately this seems okay to tenses
our I'll play these champ on to them
effects way more I'm gonna go for a key
talk with fish oh yeah we're gonna Tommy
oh my the range sweet mother of range
you see how far we're BAM
oh the spear sweet spear I gotta be I
got to be way more cautious yeah the
only other problem with this is there's
no like wide swinging ability but you
know there's always trade-offs obviously
so many bombs on the floor
[Music]
aha sweet dilating
all right got some coins we got a room
with Infinity stones we'll call them or
the room with the bag I think we're
gonna go with mystery room with the
infinity stone sure what's up al Ariza
how you doing I'm Prince within the
depths of Tartarus recite the most
wretched of all the shades who linger
for eternity within the underworld whose
Lord and Masters especially unkind to
those attempting to cheat death hurry
grab the sword miss to go around I guess
I mean the starting weapon Johnny we hit
you there buddy
if I may be so bold your highness I was
wondering what brings you back around
this way again same story along like
that you know is that we just met you
have to level with them surface I'm
leaving the house I've had quite enough
you understand I'm sure
oh that is quite an undertaking Prince
if it wasn't you yourself proposing it
I'd like to call it madness truth be
told though you'll just mad enough to
pull it off Johnny no I have it first
time playing it out there I go with help
again
thank you mate all right we're gonna get
a max health in this room which we need
let's call it even
[Music]
see over here doing some old loved one
through the like beador tactics Oh what
did I do
do not so much just think about it what
did I
[Music]
like
[Music]
we do it oh we only got six bad so we
killed everything in like 30 seconds and
we got a key O'Keefe abet okay that's
pretty cool so keep your eye out for
these chests I've never seen that before
there's a boss in that room where a gift
thing that I still don't know how to use
so go to the boss this survive for 44
seconds
can I run away
be killing this stuff I need to
okay
dad
say can I buy a potion please Thank You
Swiss jeez at least were rich what is
this new bedroom decor I get cosmetic
items at my house for 200 gold do we do
we want to buy it just for essing
giggles do we do that I don't know if
we're gonna oh you know what we're at 34
live just there's a chance we live and
not regret everything what is this this
is Hades oh yes yes
free gold and hopefully a he'll he owe
me thank goodness all right we're back
oh all right
do we get more health or get more some
man I really want a spear ability but
really we should we should really be
getting health though if we want to get
farther bedroom decor yes
can I go back I can't go back and buy
all right
does that does it let me go back and why
not let me know it doesn't let me go
back it makes sense actually oh boy this
would be the if I was proficient in the
game I think I'm just gonna go for the
hole it's like when you first play
wrenches
[Music]
and you're just like you know you need
to get HP oh and the bond guy guessing
the bomb guys
[Music]
[Music]
I need like crit attack or something so
much oh geez thank you Oh scratch that
Diablo itch a little bit it's kind of
reminding me a little bit of like dead
cells with you know some transistors I'm
bashing a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
let's get unlock a weapon back at home
shop slain pose have a 50% chance to
drop healing I'm sure 15 gold should be
not that expensive for that gain greater
power from the next boon you find
blessing from Olympians was stolen
godlike power until death whoo
we just buy everything right we're rich
look at how many stuff we have why not
right what happens if you guys it's a
roguelike yes you lose pretty much
everything except for this stuff you've
earned so you see the stuff in the
bottom right maybe sans the gold I died
I wasn't paying attention to the gold
but the purple gems you used to level up
your character that persists you get
that even if you die the keys you also
keep and it helps you unlock skills as
well as weapons so far this one has been
going better
I'm usually better with melee weapons I
want to give the bow shot because some
of those abilities and things it's a
pretty insane assuming that that's more
bow related with that feel like
I feel like what's-her-name was it
Artemis who was showing up when we had
the we had depo
so I feel like
who got the flack
oh we got some sandwiches okay that
ability seems pretty good to get from
the shop the game back
[Music]
starting to get the hang of it a little
better but much to learn obviously more
items more skills to kind of eventually
play through we can get more HP or get
some powers part of me thinks like I
should get HP just because that'll get
us farther but part of me wants
abilities I think since we took HP last
time I'll go this way
so what happens in this game I think
you're just trying to get as far as you
can you know get that oh there's a chest
as well as a school as well as trying to
just enjoy the gameplay mechanics and
the different like weapons and skills
that come along with it it's kind of
like that sells if you plate that
sellable or you know you know logically
where you're gonna eventually end up but
you know each run is gonna be different
the roguelike but it doesn't you're not
just like wasting your time if you're
just playing and dying because you'll
eventually also like level up your
character
item I just really get refinement and
mastery of these weapons and skills and
a pretty tight experience you know where
I have enjoyed either the black
projectile attack which is really cool
so you're trying to time that you're
kind of charge
I'm trying to deal with different enemy
types and
like compact in a projectile I can throw
my javelin and having me doing that
because I have not you rain you should
have listened all right Olympus so this
makes my the palm of power basically
makes my attack do the most have lots of
these upon the edge we're gonna do this
chest and hopefully not die but whatever
let's try it
Oh
trying to defector
lady walk
whatever I took way too much damage
there is this an epic game it's just on
their epic games on the epic game stores
made by supergiant games who helped
craft transistor Bastion higher to you
as well that mate
[Music]
no way we can afford the ability to so
I'm gonna do that Ares and you would
find the monkeys whereas this gift all
right unfortunately only three rares
would have been nice to get an epic your
special causes foes to suffer more
damage a moment later so that's our
throw attack this is the one that throws
the rifts blade out which is pretty cool
I like it I think this might be a good
combination with our attacks or we turn
into a blade rift ourself I guess you
guys want to check this one out let's
check this one out since we already got
the oh it's got delayed I think I should
have read it because I think it said
that our dash is slower oh well just try
something new for you guys Eric are you
enjoying the game yeah I am quite a bit
actually well this is awkward
one of the series sisters crap I've
never gotten this far she looks cool I
like the one when you live I know
besides don't you have someplace else to
be a good little man I think you got
whip of some sort I'll have to go with
the painful way we're gonna have to see
how this goes
-
[Music]
make there are the theory
Wow what a crazy attack oh my day
Oh
nobody good news a person flies
cashier took the blade
[Music]
yeah it's a the only good news about
responding that we can get
oh she does that right after
this is not a good ability I all right
some of the it's one of those things
where some of those abilities definitely
will take more skill to be better at and
choose for that make that I like the
acknowledgment of who you can guide to
you like it was way slower than this - I
really needed the - at the age of the
Dead to meet it constantly within the
house complaining of their walls also
seeking audience to see now you guys
Scala's know thanks for tuning in again
SWAT live we're playing Hades early
access game play or early access the
game rather today oh this is back I can
give him a gift shall we give them the
gift sure let's see what happens look
what I got for you boy as one of
Cerberus heads receives the princess
gift another muscle something back into
his hand
thank you boy I can't wait to hear the
tale in that case I'll spare you the
details fine your failure is quite
easily imagined how often recurs you
hear you wind every single soul that's
ever lived but by all means continue
struggling well yeah I mean a lot of it
too is just learning you know what's
good also there's some luck involved
than what you get reflect right now and
get another ability
this is pretty good this is basically
like a cheap death so you get back to 20
HP one time in your run which means
you're basically cheating death once
right this seems pretty good too because
you can do two - instead of just one
we can buy both let's get this and I
feel like I barely do that and let's do
cheat death
although you guys probably want to see
the shield huh cuz I can either buy the
shield or get the cheat death you guys
might want to see the shield we only
have time for one more run though so
I'll try the shield out if I die hella
fast we can we can do another run but
here we'll mock the shield up enough
shield of chaos
[Music]
[Music]
so basically we're Captain America combo
the punch enjoy cool Bonjour hello we're
gonna now try the shield out the only
other weapon that you can buy currently
looks like there's a lot more crashing
waves the trident looks like it's uncle
number 2 uncle not to be and in the name
of Hades this make sent this message
Seiden you're not gonna do things first
you get yourself out of that dour
underworld for me I'll see if I can stir
things up a bit to cover your bass all
right
tempers strike your texts deal more
damage and knock foes away not close
away
you're special which is why which is our
throw it deals more damage and knocks
clothes away or your cast which is our B
attack damages foes in a small area and
knocks them away I wish this deflected
you mean you're crying like Captain
America maybe it's not back on the throw
or on the cast I'm always about these
tempest yeah the damaged one right
that's what I do
oh wow having that second - is feels
really good
Oh does it really kept it all do it
bounces that's why that is oh no this is
such a hard choice we get damage upgrade
or we can get more HP our we're gonna
get more HP because that'll get us
farther into the run which is what I
want you because I oh wait oh wait yeah
you can you can destroy those attack
you know kind of sounds like caps when
it bounces off the wall oh the only
problem was throwing it when it bounces
that many times you don't have
I guess like God
that means off the punch off the attack
like the knock back it cancels someone
in channelling attack - dude all the
weapons feel good so far I have man but
if you want to be captain
oh I haven't even done though
Oh
dude like the other thing I want to
preface this I again this is this could
be the kind of game that might not look
as cool watching it I think it still
does well I also know that someone
earlier was like oh this doesn't look
that cool or that fun and I will say
this I feel like you will enjoy more
playing as well as just spectating but
we don't need any more land now now we
need a key for the cheat death someway
take the key
dude and then the knockbacks is like
[Music]
with Bucky
[Music]
you pull that be all chain pummeling
them into the wall as a first boss room
but just based I only have one second -
like I think I would've
I was getting - Yolo else and that was
bad my own shield was forged much later
in its image you know Pete yes that way
I should've got for Poseidon sir oh we
gotta take the epic right oh but it's
only way the RO but it bounces so
probably that I'm not taking slower -
and yeah we're taking that big money to
the singer what hold you to change how
look - that's sick
we need more HB oh yes sorry PHP let's
say the gift stuff gets you cosmetics I
think we're gonna do pom pom we're gonna
do a pom pom to get the wall slam
stronger
he's also shopping oh that's pretty cool
so the charge attack is the deflection
whatever I forgot what it's called
whatever the charge attack is this one
but their attachment to it appears that
it will like
[Music]
simple God's grant me strength or we can
deflect thanks it's only 15 percent more
damage versus 25% more damage and it can
deflect I think we're ready aim the
knock back so I guess we just need
oh here's the cheat death we can get
cheat death without getting the skill or
should we save our Gold's in case and I
don't think I'm gonna die well we'll see
we can do this chest and then get the
cheat death or we get the cheap death
just in case and then we're gonna get
gold back anyways
[Music]
saying that it ends up like the
under the darkness 75 good Oh what was
that I don't know what the purple thing
was um let's buy the cheap death yeah
yeah let's buy the cheap after that
because we're gonna get more golden and
then Oh give us a chance reminds me
expiries oh yeah here easy bed doesn't
working in faucet right
time to collect all right we get the
Infinity stones around I think that's it
right
hey hey hey so huh chinder well it says
I like how you been without knowing
about it I ain't seen you realizes a
supergiant game yes
yeah furious was pretty fun too hey boys
I feel like had a little bit more
schmoopy stuff happening though but now
you know it's been alright all things
considered dying now and then and it's
been hard but hey what can you do well
keep your chin up me why I quit trying
to get out of here a while back
but if I was a fire stepping youngster
like yourself perhaps I would have stuck
to it
right taking the help
sure thing
I really need that one ability where HP
drops like 15% of time
that's the one downside the shield
you're not getting it back for a while
and you just have to dodge or I have to
dodge better
all right Poseidon or more health I
really want that but this will help us
get farther I no risk no reward right
oh boy the other we get both beside this
message
- is slightly slower but can the black
no thank you
receive 165 gold as desired or fifthly
gold I guess strength of the goddess
you never turn your back against the sea
and while you're at it you never take up
sides against your greatest uncle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
got a corner on my campus I needed to
corner them and like just keep wall
slamming them that's my bad this game
will reach seem question mark I don't
know it's just on the epic store right
now tidal surge instead of your - you
ride a damaging damage dealing wave
after clearing encounters gain more gems
gold and HP than usual that seems pretty
good slang flows into the walls or
corner stuns them done we got to take
the stun right there's no way we're not
taking this done in this room with 18
health with a cheat death oh we can buy
food thank the heavens we can buy
everything are we fighting the boss
already are we already at Furies all
right we're blind
stun duration five seconds yes thank you
by the food by skill he doesn't talk too
much and since neither to you I'm
letting you have this
what are you have to let me have our
true shot your cast deals more damage
okay so that's the thing that did a
bunch of damage earlier for us after you
- the attack deals crit damage any
damage you deal has a chance to just
crit ten percent probably this one right
- and then crit cuz I don't
all right good luck to us I got to see
you at game eight good luck to us if
this is fearless if it's an old girl nag
of course it is time to dig deep
maybe my whip might make you reconsider
whatever it is that you're attempting
here your whips nothing all that
persuasive I don't want to can't we just
be friends
[Music]
[Music]
you know what I regret not having the
[Music]
oh that's so new
[Music]
I don't know how oh there goes
[Music]
okay now it's like your he's pretty good
No I was trying to
yeah I was trying to see at least if we
could push her to another phase but
unfortunately not the case okay she got
me definitely got me hooked though this
game and I definitely want to beer by
the way Eric didn't even mention Greg
could have been a good plug yeah
if you guys didn't know Greg cassava
used to work at GameSpot a long time ago
he currently works maybe not well pretty
long time ago now he works at supergiant
games we've been there making those
games for a while now but yeah that was
awesome I had a fun time actually Wow
pretty good on timing to that I died
there thank you guys all for tuning into
GameSpot live we are live Monday to
Friday 11:00 a.m.
come back tomorrow as there's a bunch of
different cool events happening tomorrow
I think we're gonna do overwatch at
11:00 a.m. for the winter wonderland but
don't forget that you know destiny is
having their dawning event and also call
duty black ops 4 is gonna have a new
section on blackout I think it's like
snowy and then I think there's also a
new operator as well so definitely come
back tomorrow come hang out with us we
really appreciate it if you haven't
subscribed you should we had some really
cool features just go up during the
weekend if you want to know more about
outer worlds I believe Peter got a
chance to see the game and he talked to
rob about it go check that out it's
pretty cool that's on YouTube right now
of course if you wanna check that out
also on GameSpot calm and then the other
cool feature was we got to have an
exclusive gameplay demo of ancestors uh
it's human world Odyssey if I or
humankind Odyssey is easy I think it's
humankind Odyssey I'll double-check that
but Mike got to check that out with
Patrice desolace assuming I said his
last name correct so if you want to get
a first peek at that that's also up on
GameSpot calm as well as YouTube both
really cool features we're gonna have
more stuff coming out with best of the
year coming up soon ish we started
putting up some of our report cards in
terms of like yearly reviews of
PlayStation Xbox Place PC and Nintendo
so yeah really appreciate you guys and
gals hanging out and until next time go
check out hades 1999 on the epic store
for early access right now but i'm sure
also eventually
come out 2019 but if you want to get a
your hands on it now that's the way to
do it and see y'all later peace